unlike Nvidia and AMD with the RX 7600
XT launch we're not going to waste
anyone's time with Bullit today the
answer is 1 to 3% that is the percent
Improvement of the 480 super over the
original 480 we spent 20 hours testing
and validating that Behavior Uh and now
we can produce our one sentence review
which is 1 to 3% better for the 4080
super so thank you everyone for watching
and uh go to the store to support us see
you the only thing good about the 480
super and the only thing worth talking
about is the price nvidia's official
price for it's $1,000 now down from
$1,200 for the original 4080 and they
are functionally the same card for all
intents and purposes for benchmarking
gaming performance you should think of
them as identical the difference between
the two it basically amounts to noise
like it it wouldn't even show up as
meaningful if the test environment isn't
clean enough so uh if this were still
$1,200 the 480 super then the review
would probably be about one of the most
aggressive reviews we would possibly put
together similar to the 4060 TI last
year because it would be a massive waste
of everybody's time and attention and
the same price but Nvidia has learned
this time it launched a boring product
with a better price and that actually
genuinely does complicate things a lot
the 4080 as we said in our launch review
was never worth $1,200 it didn't make
sense for workstation users like us
unfortunately the lack of vram it
actually genuinely does matter a lot on
the 480 versus the 490 so Nvidia
succeeded in creating an actual tiering
difference between its top end and its
next down which historically they were a
lot closer uh than they are today and
and because of that the price has grown
the gulf has grown between them and
that's probably partly because Nvidia
knows that the professional audience
really doesn't have many options at the
highend anyway the trouble with all this
is that the 480 never should have been
$1,200 to begin with which does
complicate the price drop as well
because it's not as simple as just
congratulating Nvidia and saying good
job you dropped the price everybody's
happy now uh because they're just kind
of bringing it back to maybe closer to
expectations and that makes the price
reduction of the 480 super feel some
kind of Stockholm syndrome it is kind of
a good thing and the value certainly
improves but it's also difficult to
praise something that has moved from
complete Insanity to moderately deranged
uh and that's what we're going to be
looking at in the review today
traditionally many years ago the 480
super would not exist in this capacity
it would have been a price cut and used
to do those more often we' get press
releases where they give us the lineup
of their whole uh GPU stack normally
around or just before or after an amdgpu
launch until it wasn't in it at the time
and the News was hey the price cut uh
improves the value and that was about it
it was not as often a new card as we get
today so taking this approach means that
Nvidia gets to strap a sticker to the
end of the existing card with
functionally the same performance again
uh in ways where the changes are not
meaningful and generate some Buzz
clearly it's working we're talking about
it probably a lot of other people are
too because it's a new card uh rather
than just doing the price cut where it
gets covered in news and everyone kind
of moves on so they're they're
definitely adapting the strategy anyway
let's review this card this review won't
be like any of our other GP reviews for
the last few weeks so we've done massive
amounts of charts some of these reviews
were like 30 40 charts uh to really
prove the work and show how things have
changed but because this one is so
simple we are keeping the review very
simple and we're going to boil it down
to really just a few metrics here and
some General Industry discussion so this
just to Prime everyone is a little less
structured for the amount of data if you
want it there's a few ways you can get
it one we're going to just publish all
the charts and a mega charts thing on
the website that'll contain the 480
super data on it on Gamers nexus.net
we'll run a separate video to do a bunch
of other updates when that happens you
can get it there if you really want the
raw absolute FPS numbers the other
option you have and this is a sincere uh
recommendation from me is you can go to
any one of our charts the 4080 published
in the last couple weeks and you can
multiply the number FPS that the 480 is
against 1% if you want the low end or 3%
if you want the upper bound you add them
together uh and there's your difference
uh so that would be how you can quickly
calculate it and yes it really is that
simple at 1080p sure you might have some
truncation from cvu bottlenecks or
whatever but it doesn't really matter
cuz we're talking 1 to 3% okay so
instead of going completely ham and
doing all the latency efficiency and
everything else that we originally
planning to do let's just get straight
into kind of the recap of everything
here's the specs the 480 super as
reminder has 10,240 caor and uses a
perfect 80103 die the original 480 was
also 80103 but it was cut down from 9728
kudor this could have been for yield
reasons there's also obviously some
natural product segmentation built into
this as well uh but normally the yields
improve as the process matures and so
it's not uncommon for uh GP manufactur
to open up the die a little more the end
result is that the new 480 super has
5.3% more Cuda cor but it also has an
advertised clock bump it's just very
slight and here's the chart to join the
recap we could spend 30 minutes chart
spamming to show our work like normally
but this one really just doesn't deserve
it uh and no one should watch that
anyway so this summarizes it pretty well
genuinely you could multiply any of
these percentages uh against the 4080
results on a chart from a week ago as
long as you know which one you're
looking at and you get a rough idea for
where it lands with the 4070 TI super
launch and the relative lameness of that
card we said it seemed possible that
Nvidia was couching its weakest launch
between its two better cards the 4070
super and we thought the 4080 super for
performance that speculation didn't pan
out unfortunately for the 480 super and
uh our interest levels in testing it but
the value is actually better and so
that's what makes this anything worth
talking about at all as we've SE said uh
however the original assumption that the
4070 TI would be the most boring one
that was incorrect it might actually be
this one just from raw performance
anyway back to that 480 vers 480 super
chart we weren't expecting a world of
change with the specs change but we were
expecting a little better than an
average uplift of say 1.9% here's a
quick comparison of the rx700 XTX versus
the 480 super first showing only rate
trace and isolation because the
advantage flips uh and the favor is
toward Nvidia here whereas the raster
favor is toward AMD in this chart we see
the unbelievable lead andv holds in
cyberpunk R tracing which we just re
added to the test Suite when running
Ultra RT settings and then there's a
disproportionate advantage that falls as
RT settings are reduced we see this with
medium going from a 60 plus% Nvidia
favor to about a 30% favor still huge at
Rough price equivalent uh but it's a a
big differ and d light 2 shares at least
the medium sort of percentages Resident
Evil favors AMD here and is a lighter RT
workload so that makes sense Tomb Raider
and F1 are also both medium to
lightweight RT workloads and that gives
us a fairly full picture of the types of
RT games right now we have those which
heavily leverage rate tracing and swing
the performance towards Nvidia in big
ways and we have those which supplement
more and impact it less heavily here's
the rasterization comparison between
these two AMD leads or is equal with the
480 super overall it's anywhere from
about again equal to 20% ahead in raster
performance with particular strengths in
Starfield at 4K dite 2 at 4K Resident
Evil at 4K and our testing uh F1 at 4K
as well and 1440p that's actually not
bad at 1080p for that one uh despite
approaching bottleneck if you mostly
play non rate tracing titles or you
aren't interested in using the feature
in heavy RT games like cyber Punk and
Allen wake 2 then the 7900 XTX might be
better value but it really just depends
what kind of games you want to play on
your card one additional note here too
for F1 and Total War the 1080p result
would also increase similarly to the
1440p result but it gets truncated
because we start running into external
bottlenecks at this class of card that
makes sense so let's talk about that
aspect that's the most interesting thing
today anyways the value we don't
normally do FPS per dollar or dollar per
FPS chart uh for a few reasons there's
they're definitely useful it's just that
they require some caveat and they aren't
quite as objective as we'd like them to
be number that comes out of the end of
it is somewhat useless you don't really
care about the dollar number you care
about how big is that bar compared to
the other bars and we'll talk about that
more later in this review at the end but
a lot of you request these uh and they
definitely have their place and this is
the place just doing a especially a
head-to-head with cards that are
relatively close in price so um one
other note here too is that these types
of charts shed all of the Nuance so any
discussion
about potential uh efficiency power
efficiency professional workload uh
frame pacing and frame delivery you lose
all of that here where you would have at
least the frame pacing and say an
average to 0.1% low chart but still
useful it's a different type of chart
for us let's try it out here's 1440p for
the 480 vers 480 super if we were to
draw a line at an approximate average
it'd be in the $8 to $9 per FPS range
for the original 480 uh 6.5 to 7.5 for
the 480 super generally speaking you can
see from The Gap that the 48 to 480
super where lower is better improves by
a similar amount per C and again the
actual dollar number doesn't really
matter because the FPS is just you make
it basically whatever you want depending
on the games but the difference is what
matters and it's improved for
perspective let's look at these numbers
as a percent reduction in cost per frame
this is just the percent Improvement
where we're defining Improvement as
reduction cost per frame from the 480 to
the 480 super the reduction in USD per
FPS tends to be about 177% so if you
wanted an objective look at the change
in value or at least as much of an
objective look as we could get which
inherently has some subjectivity to it
depending on the buyer's situation this
is about as close as we'll be able to do
it between two cards just a quick fun
Point here too to make uh an example of
marketing math depending on if you are
Nvidia
or a normal human you could say it's
177% better than the 4080 or you could
say it's 1 to3 % better obviously
depending on which of those metrics you
want to promote as we said earlier this
entire launch is functionally just a
price reduction of an existing product
it's a good thing to reduce the price
they've done it in a little bit of a
confusing way with all the different
names that are out there now and we
wonder whether the cost to Fab cut down
480 die is meaningfully lower than the
new 480 super die because if it is and
if we ignore it nvidia's desire for
maintaining aspn margin that it might
have been more exciting to cut that M RP
further doesn't normally work that way
though then it' look like an admission
of a bad launch price it would reduce
the average selling price and so maybe
that was never in the cars as we said
last year Nvidia had an RTX 480 problem
where no one was buying them for some
time it's kind of the opposite of the
490 which everyone seems to want the GPU
Market has definitely changed in that
regard but let's look at some more
numbers the next ones look at the 7800
XTX we're also using 1440p for these we
have 4K numbers of course but uh 1440
allows us to pretty much show anything
and we're showing off an average of a
selection of cards available at
retailers this table shows our work for
picking the price when we do the price
performance comparisons currently the
average 700 XTX will cost about $985 in
the US from the two largest retail
options the cheapest option yesterday
was the Phantom gaming at $940 which
seems to be in good Supply it's tough to
know which price to use for the chart
coming up since the instant promos are
likely temporary and to compete with
this launch so to simplify things will
make them more complicated so what we do
best will'll use the best price and the
average price that's $940 and
$985 and remember that the average 480
super is likely to Trend above $1,000 as
well but they don't exist when we're
filming this here's the price per frame
chart we have two values for the 7800
XTX to make the comparison first looking
at RT performance particularly in
cyberpunk with ultra settings AMD is
getting killed for Value but that was
expected because if you remember this
specific test produces massive double
digit percentage Point increases with
Nvidia over AMD the medium results are
less intensive for the rate traced
workload again and as a result the
numbers leveled out Nvidia still
produces a better value per frame though
in d light 2 Nvidia again maintains an
advantage against both AMD price points
Resident Evil favors AMD F1 with rt
marginally favors Nvidia and tomb rated
with rt has them about equal now if we
look at rasterization performance AMD
generally has an advantage it's
typically below or roughly equal to
Nvidia and the games that are in the
bottom half of uh of the chart for
rasterization amd's performance is
typically higher in these not always or
it's very close uh and so that's
benefiting it for the value of these
versus some of those RT benchmarks
here's the percent reduction in cost per
frame with rt moving to the 480 super
from the XTX at 985 for the XTX the
reduction cost per FPS for the 480 super
despite a higher base cost is 38% for
cyberpunk with ultra RT 20% at medium or
In Dying Light 9% for F1 and 5% for Tomb
Raider MD has an advantage in our
Resident Evil tests at $940 those
numbers reduced to 35% 16% 4 and a half
and equality in Tomb Raider let's look
at the rasterization and flip the chart
because the XTX tends to be better in
these tests the reduction in cost per
FPS now favors AMD buying AMD instead of
Nvidia here would give you a 15% lower
cost per frame at $940 in Starfield
Resident Evil 4 20% in F1 177% in Total
War Nvidia has a drop driver overhead
advantage in our testing approach for
Final Fantasy 14 so it levels out there
and the $985 options lose some of that
value advantage of course but you'd
still need to determine if they have
features you value more than the 45
bucks and there's still ahead of Nvidia
there so that's some new ways to maybe
visualize the data you can let us know
what you think of it uh a lot of people
request these we've done them a couple
times in the past but always have to
explain couple of the reservations we
have because well actually this next
chart is an even better representation
of it so we're going to look at nvidia's
progress on value and the chart we're
going to show it's functionally a
similar concept of the value calculation
but it's useful because we're going to
look at nvidia's full current lineup and
what we're looking to identify is has it
improved so as as at a glance as
possible is NVIDIA actually moving in
the right direction or does it just kind
of feel like it or are we
being Stockholm syndromes into thinking
they're moving in the right direction
this chart kind of helps answer that
question more objectively couple notes
here so price per frame value like this
gets fuzzy when you exit direct
head-to-head comparisons and you do kind
of a a wideband chart of everything and
that's for reasons we explained earlier
but our main reservations about this
kind of chart are how people actually
shop uh which I'll talk about another
one this is me just kind of explaining
it to you all because you know these are
not charts we typically show they're
highly requested they're kind of
interesting we think there's usefulness
there I don't know if we're going to use
them reviews ever again kind of depends
what people think but whenever we
introduce something new we like to
explain our thought process to how we
got to the Chart um and what our our
problems with it are out of full
transparency so one of the other issues
that I have with these types of charts
is it's it's an abstraction away from an
abstraction away from an abstraction
away from the base metric of time so if
we're looking at percent value which is
kind of based well is directly based
upon the cost per frame per second
metric which is based on frames per
second which is an abstraction itself
away from time frame time it's so many
steps that if you think about it too
hard it starts to mean nothing and some
of the but it's fun uh and and maybe
you'll find it useful we tried to do our
best here um to to meet the audience
demand for this type of thing as for how
people actually shop generally speaking
people have a budget in mind or they're
determining it and then they'll buy
within a range roughly that means a
head-to-head chart is definitely useful
for Value but very few people would say
I only want to buy the best dollar per
frame card ignore all other nuance and
then pick whatever has the best value on
a chart because it's probably going to
end up being like a $300 card uh and it
doesn't normally work that way these
charts also smooth over nuances so that
means again we lose frame pacing we lose
the frame buffer uh potential advantages
things like that and one last thing too
just to note that the uh the dollars are
not cross comparable at all between
reviews certainly um and even
necessarily within a review they're kind
of really only just work on the same
chart that's cuz they're they're
basically arbitrary uh it's not like
frame rate or temperature or something
where there's some kind of threshold of
objectively uh below this number is not
tolerable and it completely changes
based on the math you put into it of
course if you have 800 FPS totally
different number anyway our pricing here
was taken by averaging reasonable cards
available for each of nvidia's SKS
and the 490 when we checked was not
available for MSRP unfortunately the
average price appeared to be about
$2,000 so that's what we use for this
one one other reservation about this
chart this is just my TED talk about uh
the challenges with making charts that
are kind of abstractions for for things
like value but these charts also skew
heavily depending on whether you're
using 4K 1440 1080 uh not even
necessarily just because of bottl ax
that might start appearing at lower
resolutions but more importantly because
the the percent scaling of performance
changes
where you'll see some cards do a lot
better A lot worse at say 4K than at
1080 uh and so depending
on the chart's kind of smooth over that
too so anyway you understand our
reservations about them and they are
many but let's just get to the damn
chart because that's what people want
and I do think they can have value
anyway here it is this is new again
we're not sure if we like it that's your
disclaimer no big claims for this one uh
it might go away in the future but we
might also rework it 100% is Baseline
best value of the cards presented on
this chart where value is determined as
the dollar per FPS number the result has
the 460 as the cheapest per FPS so it's
at 100% the 490 is about half the quote
unquote value of that uh if we want to
make the decision as a community to
phrase it that way and one of those
major nuances is the fact that a 4060
for example could never do some of the
things a 4090 could do and you can't
really represent that here but
regardless what this does is tell us the
direction Nvidia is going by this chart
it would in fact appear that the 480
Super's new price drop has improved its
quote unquote value the 480 is among the
worst on the chart and lacks some of
those nuances that a 490 provides for
instance despite being a so-called low
value by this chart the 490 is still the
only one on this list that we would buy
for our editing machines due to the VR
and that's not something that gets
measured here anyway it's kind of a lot
of talk about just we're playing around
with charts numbers and ideas because
the uh the audience is is constantly
providing concepts for new things we've
debuted a lot of them recently it's fun
to
um and we just bake it into reviews at
this point but anyway the the takeaway
here strictly from the perspective of is
NVIDIA making things better value or not
at least for the 4080 super it appears
to be yes and even if you just remove
all of this and look at the fact that
the price came down $200 but it's
basically the same product the answer is
yes we don't really need the chart to
prove that uh what's more interesting is
looking at things like the 4070 the 4070
super uh and the ti super to try and
gauge value there and um generally
speaking as you go up the stack the
value tends to get worse that's
historically been true the 470 super
helped to revive some of that the ti
super unfortunately was a bit of a dud
and and the 480 super we come back to
the same thing from the very beginning
which is it's cheaper none of the plan
around with charts and numbers and
trying to do something interesting using
the review as an opportunity to explore
different presentation methods none of
it changes the fact that uh the only
other alternative here for charts would
be 30 minutes of me losing my mind
increasingly probably using an
increasing amount of and stronger grade
of adjectives to describe the 480 Su
performance such as for example
mindblowing 1.92 36 78% Improvement
which is one of the biggest percent
improvements we've ever seen if you
ignore the decimal that's the kind of
commentary you lose but no one needs 30
minutes of that so uh The price came
down the only Factor at this stage that
we are considering is basically that the
7800 XTX is now effectively the direct
alternative to the 480 or 480 super uh
where previously the XTX was cheap
enough at that $200 drop typically
sometimes more where you might not even
be a customer if you were trying to
spend $11,000 and not 1,200 because
that's a big increase in this case we
can't praise Nvidia for basically doing
what it it should have done a long time
ago we can however say that this is a
better situation uh our hesitation again
to fully embrace the product kind of
goes back to not getting suckered into
believing this is kind of the the new
method for keeping the average price is
High um but it's at least improved now
all that said one thing we noticed as as
a positive and our efficiency testing
the 7600 XT review was that the 4080 had
kind of we had a new found appreciation
for it where previously we had very
little um at least based on the original
kind of review performance numbers
products at the time it came out but the
new found appreciation was specifically
for efficiency where in terms of
performance per watt or however you want
to look at that the 480 was actually
impressive and the 480 super is
basically the same thing here just a
little bit better still so um that's
something that a review overhauls are
helping us see which is pretty cool
anyway that's it for now you have enough
to work with and make your decisions uh
it's the same thing but cheaper and
we'll publish as many of the raw FPS
numbers as we can get together in our
next Mega charts update but this was
kind of just a way for us to recap and
and cool down and come to the end of
this massive review cycle where we've
done is this the fourth GPU I guess this
is the fourth GPU and then the two CPUs
and we have more CPUs coming in um but
we're at the end of it that's your kind
of big picture overview of how Nvidia is
doing in the market and thanks for
watching subscribe more you can go to
store. g.net support us directly go
check out the AMD staff video from
yesterday uh super cool stuff a lot of
discoveries in there that are are really
interesting and we'll see you all next
time